les services ne sont
redonnent un tout petit coup de
chauffeuse à Michel là on est à 1125
notez la recette pour réussir la cuisson
d'une statue de Jeanne d'Arc
la température initiale de l'alliage
qui ensuite deviendra un bronze solide
doit être obligatoirement supérieur à
1025 degrés pour qu'il reste liquide au
moment décisif de la couler
nous on jongle avec les alliages pour
obtenir ce que l'on veut ce que l'on
désire et un bronzda en fait c'est
simplement le pourcentage de cuivre qui
détermine un bronze d'art si à 65% de
cuivre à l'intérieur c'est un bronzard
pour cet allage là on va prendre plutôt
des caractéristiques mécaniques un peu
plus élevées puisque c'est un monument
donc les gens risquent d'aller dessus et
puis de faire un peu les idiots s'il y a
une manifestation donc là on va jouer
plutôt la sécurité top
l'alliage est ici coulé dans le moule en
plâtre qui va lui donner sa forme
définitive
il est composé de 96% de cuivre 3% de
silicium et quelques pincées de
manganèse
ensuite on fournit et patienter
mais patientez vraiment le temps d'une
grosse ellipse la pièce doit rester dans
le four 15 jours minimum avant l'étape
suivante le démoulage
c'est ça c'est le plâtre rétracteur
la cire il était dedans voilà
toute cette fragile si elle était un
globée par par des kilos de culot de
plâtre
le décor et les gestes qui semblent ne
pas avoir changé depuis des siècles
peuvent faire croire par moment qu'on
est dans un roman d'Émile Zola
même si tout de même quelques outils
modernes viennent alléger la tâche de
l'ouvrier
[Musique]
grâce au travail du nettoyeur haute
pression on voit apparaître peu à peu un
visage
le créateur va bientôt redécouvrir son
œuvre qui va falloir ensuite embellir
il faudra reprendre ici en ciselure tout
ce qui est système d'attaque
d'alimentation là on a mis le métal
liquide là on attaque la pièce donc il y
aura tout ça à rectifier à la ciselure
il y a aussi un rectifier cette petite
queue de rat qui était le long du visage
ici donc il faudra l'éliminer ensuite
évidemment il faudra faire les montages
des bras également puisque les bras sont
coulés à part et il faudra évidemment
remettre la partie du bas aussi donc ça
ça se fait par soudure
[Musique]
à ce stade Jeanne d'Arc n'est qu'un
buste demain elle récupérera des bras et
des jambes